[Musique]
ces vies bonjour bonjour vous êtes l'un
des plus grands patrons français
vous avez fait de l' agence de pub
publicis le troisième groupe de
communication au monde et on va voir
avec vous comment votre parcours s'est
construit pour faire de cette entreprise
un géant mais d'abord je voudrais qu'on
regarde ensemble cette image les voeux
depuis un certain nombre d'années
la nouvelle année je faisais ou petite
vidéo pouteau roland va essayer d'être
drôle et je n'hésitais pas à jouer de la
dérision et à mettre en selle en
mutilant l'image l'idée c'est quoi c'est
d'être un patron à torok le poil départ
c'était une cérémonie de voeux
classiques un message de voeux adressés
acmn et puis ensuite ce que j'ai fait ça
a été dit ah bon tout ça est ennuyeux et
si on de le rendre un peu plus amusant
donc dont j'avais eu en fait ça a été
les voeux en chine mois ah oui en
chinois et puis après on ne jamais se
prendre trop au sérieux
cependant un peu mais pas trop d'accord
alors votre destin est lié évidemment à
publicis puisque vous êtes rentré dans
l'entreprise à 29 ans en 1971 et à
l'époque vous y rentrer comme
responsable de l'informatique donc on
est loin de la pub
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'est ce que
représentait publicis pour vous à
l'époque vous avez intégré l'entreprise
a cité magique
c'était la plus belle agence était aussi
les drugstores c'était la modernité
novation et avec un personnage c'était
absolument intouchable étaient tous là
haut qui était le fondateur marcel
bleustein blanchet qu'on voit là à
l'image qui est en gros celui qui a
inventé la pub d'une certaine façon en
france
absolument toute la pub moderne c'est
marcel c'est lui qui a rompu la réclame
et c'est lui qui a donné à la publicité
ses lettres de noblesse qui est dit il
faut respecter les consommateurs il faut
respecter la marque
il faut traiter les gens avec
intelligence il faut cesser de les
prendre pour des imbéciles
donc il y là il a fait un travail
considérable sur le plan de l'éthique et
de la déontologie
un travail qui d'ailleurs est restée
collée à notre peau de où toutes les
valeurs de publicis et vient depuis
l'origine de ce que marcel lausanne
tâche a créé donc cette entreprise qu'il
a créée et publicis elle vous faisait
rêver étant jeune elle faisait rêver
tout le monde à part il faut pas se
tromper
à l'époque il y avait qu une agence où
il fallait passer c'était publicis en
plus c'était brillant la créativité
depuis si c'était un autre pareil dans
les concours internationaux publicis a
raflé la majorité des prix qui étaient
dévolues à la france c'était un de
tristes ou be l'endroit où il fallait
être mais pas seulement même jour un
informaticien comme vous je faisais un
peu plus que de l'informatique déjà dans
la boîte où j'étais au préalable mais
même pour l'informaticien comme moi
d'accord c'était l'incarnation de la
modernité
est ce que vous vous souvenez de votre
première rencontre avec marcel bleustein
blanchet ah oui comme si c'était hier et
d'ailleurs c'était très amusant je me
demande s'il me l'ait pas fait exprès
c'était dans les meubles publicis
l'ancien avant qu'il brûle et
il m'a reçu une petite table de bridge
comme ça comme celle ci a laissé tout
beige et il était calé dans un fauteuil
-15 et j'avais un autre photo louise
s'étaient vus compris par la suite des
meubles d'époque et avec beaucoup de
bienveillance il m'avait accueilli et
j'étais très intimidée incapable de me
présenter
j'arrivais pas qu'un petit garçon avait
exactement j'étais comme un petit garçon
je n'arrivais pas et elles sont là il a
commencé à parler à se raconter et au
lieu de me pose des questions sur moi il
m'a posé des questions sur
l'informatique et là nous avons eu une
conversation a été extrêmement riche
passionnante
qu'est-ce que ça c'est vu comme une
question bah il m'a d'abord demandé
comment ça marche et alors j'essaie de
lui expliquer ça va c'est si je mets
quelque chose ici ça sort là j'y voyais
absolument ce qui est d'ailleurs la
vérité en informatique
ensuite on a commencé à gamberger un
petit peu échangé sur ce que ça pouvait
être dans l'avenir des cons 71
on est en 71 et à ce moment là on
discute ensemble et on arrive je lui dit
vous savez à un moment donné tous ces
gros ordinateurs c'était des salles
immenses un bon jour on les vendra dans
les supermarchés et alors là c'est lui
qui enchaîne et y met alors ça veut dire
que chacun aura oui absolument et on
pourra commander à pâtir de la gym oui
on pourra même commander sa pizza ou
c'est à dire qu'avec marcel bleustein
blanchet en fait lors de notre première
rencontre
vous délirez peut-être le monde de
demain
absolument authentiques alors quand vous
rentrez donc chez publicis vous êtes
chargé de mettre l'ensemble des données
de l'entreprise notamment sur bon
informatique et ça va s'avérer
déterminant
lors d'un événement qui va intervenir
quelques mois plus tard et qui va avoir
un impact extraordinaire sur
l'entreprise mais aussi sur votre
parcours
cet événement c'est celui ci
un mort 10 milliards d'anciens francs
c'est à 22h56 heroes soir que l'ancien
hôtel astoria qui abrita le pc dyson au
vert pendant la guerre fut la proie des
flammes
pour transformer en agence de publicité
ceux de l'immeuble situé à deux pas de
l'étoile abrite quotidiennement 15 100
emplois
le feu a pris dans une poubelle
pense-t-on place et rue vernet à
proximité de la porte des livraisons du
drugstore des champs-elysées cédric
store créé il y à 13 ans et elle a des
lieux les plus fréquentés
sous ce dragster un cinéma en un mot il
personne ce qu'est ce que ça vous fait
de revoir ces images quasiment quarante
ans après d'abord beaucoup d'émotion à
ce moment là quand il ya un incendie je
ne trouve par hasard sur les champs
elysées et je suis obsédé par le fait
qu'il y a des équipes de publicis qui
travailla informatiques qui sont à
l'intérieur qui chante à l'intérieur et
donc je pensais qu'on allait me laisser
entrer pour que je leur disais les gars
il faut sortir ils n'ont rien voulu
savoir et on s'est même battu
physiquement nous a confié rené bougnol
monde du conte pièces et c'est le
général perdu j'avais comme ça vous fait
quoi
au début je tourne en rond autour je
vaux marcel de salles blanches et qui
regarde l'immeuble notamment il est
saisi il est stoïque
il est rejoint par robert badinter
elisabeth badinter il est rejoint aussi
la cible des journalistes
un certain nombre de
le genre de la maison y compris à
l'époque daniel toscan du plantier et là
on imagine quoi que l'entreprise est
fichu et elle est fichue dans l'esprit
des gens et puis marsal dit écoute c'est
que l'immeuble
ce n'est qu'au limon et puis je rentre
chez moi je suis interrompu dans la nuit
par un coup de fil donc vous rentrez
chez vous et puis téléphone sonne parce
que on avait d'autres trucs soeur on
nous disait qu'il y avait des menaces et
et puis finalement je me raby et je
retourne au publicis de brûler j'essaie
de rentrer de l'autre côté
et puis je vois il devait être quatre
ans et demi 5 1 du matin ou quatre
matins je sais pas trop il ya une espèce
de jimpo de commandes car dans une veste
en cuir un cas ce que je mets tout ça me
casse je rentrais et je rentre dans
l'immeuble dans l'espoir là encore de
quoi là je voulais voir ce qui se
passait et essayer de comprendre et puis
là j'avais repris mes esprits je me suis
dit que les gens étaient déjà partis et
que peut-elle y avait des choses à
sauver pour que nous puissions
redémarrer le lendemain et vous allez
récupérer donc les les fichiers je vais
je vais à mon bus rouge dès qu un peu ce
qui se passe je tombe d'ailleurs sur la
personne qui était décédé sur son
cadavre et et à ce moment là je vois
l'ampleur des dégâts je mais il faut
absolument que je sorte les fichiers
avant que l'immeuble soit condamné et je
sens les fichiers par la fenêtre
à ce moment là est quelqu'un qui était
arrivé et commencent à les récupérer sur
le trottoir et un autre qui me rejoint
les pompiers sont débordés et ont
surtout ce que l'on peut sortir de
l'immeuble et je retrouve quelques
heures plus tard vers 9h ou 10h du matin
marcel bleustein blanchet
il faisait un petit réunion avenue
marceau nous avions des bureaux et des
bons ce qu'on va pouvoir payer les gens
est ce qu'on va pouvoir
je ne sais pas je pense que oui on va
essayer en tout cas ce qu'assure et on
va partir de suite sont occupés et il
fait sa déclaration
rentrez chez vous ne vous inquiétez pas
publicis continue vous serez payé à la
fin du moins parce que vous êtes rentrés
pendant l' incendie pour récupérer les
fichiers informatiques
oui comment est ce qu'on est prêt à
risquer sa vie pour une entreprise quand
c'est pas la vôtre est la conscience la
passion l'amour pour cette maison à
laquelle je m'étais profondément
attachés en si peu de temps j'avais
l'impression c'était ma maison j'ai eu
ce sentiment très vite
et heureusement que
que le gendarme était l'homme qui
m'avait recruté avant marcel bleustein
blanchet a eu cette intuition qu'il
fallait absolument transformer
l'informatique de publicis autrement
plus messi n'aurait jamais redémarrer
donc en gros vous sauver la boîte
n'exagérons rien mais en tous les cas je
donne à toutes les équipes des quelques
jours après les moyens de travailler
qu'est-ce que ça comme impact sur votre
parcours
cet événement-là objectivement quand je
le fais et dans les jours qui ont suivi
je pense mais très honnêtement
absolument pas un mois non mais y'a mon
parcours mes aises mais c'est vrai que
pour marcel bleustein blanchet c'était
étonnant de voir que j'avais pris ces
risques et ce qui était encore plus
étonnant ce n'est pas que j'ai pris des
risques c'est que finalement tout ce que
j'ai fait et apporter des résultats mais
ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir un lien de
confiance à peu près irréversible entre
vous et lui il y a quelque chose qui
s'était déjà noué le premier jour
puisqu'il avait conclu l'entretien le
premier jour et 10 ans je l'homme un
jour les régions à cette maison et il va
tenir promesse je sais pas si c'était
une promesse mais en tous les cas
oui il va tenir cette promesse
mais ce n'était pas une promesse c'est
moi qui ai cru ma femme me demandait de
redescendre un petit peu voyeur
c'est le morcellement ça en me disant
tout simplement il doit dire ça à tous
les nouveaux d'accord c'est une façon de
vous motiver c'est comme ça qu'elle
avait interprété
alors à partir de là effectivement vous
allez gravir tous les échelons de
l'entreprise
deux patrons de l'informatique vous
devenez secrétaire général puis
directeur général adjoint puis directeur
général et en 1988
marcel bleustein-blanchet vous nomme
président du directoire de publicis et
lui devient président donc du conseil de
surveillance
drôle que jamais l'europe actuellement
et là vous donc
définissez une stratégie vous allez le
voir en lui disant je veux faire de
publicis un géant mondial du podium
mondial
une entreprise mondiale oui je lui dis
peut plus simplement je pense que si
nous voulons exister dans l'avenir il va
falloir que nous soyons mondiaux nos
clients ont des marchés partout ils vont
être progressivement amené à avoir une
stratégie de communication à l'échelle
mondiale
il faut donc nous soyons nous mêmes
mondiaux autrement nous allons perdre
nos clients qu'est ce qu'il dit alors il
m'écoute et me dit et où je pars à les
états unis il mémorise s'agit ni vous
plaisantez
qu'est ce qu'on va leur apporter ils
sont beaucoup plus forts que nous c'est
quentin ventes et le marketing s'était
contenté la publicité mais il n'a pas
totalement tort enfin à l'écouté en même
temps on peut comprendre ces gaulois
comme publicis va aller faire
en fait comme
publicité mondiale alors que vous avez
les américains qui dominent le marché
oui c'est vrai et tout ça a été juste et
c'était parfaitement raisonner mais en
même temps je lui disais mais étaient
dans ce cas ils vont nous piquer tous
les budgets
pourquoi tous nos clients qui sont un
peu internationaux à un moment donné
auront besoin d'agencés internationales
si nous sommes pas capables de les
servir au brésil au mexique au
kazakhstan en inde et en chine qui
s'ouvrait à peine à ce moment là la
chine était encore ouverte et donc vous
gratuits sont épaulés la nuance
il faut que nous soyons et mimiques
comment est-ce qu'on va se positionner
c'est là où je nous sommes et lui et moi
mais surtout lui mais moi comme lui donc
je ne me place pas à son niveau
extrêmement attachés à notre francité
alors donc c est une entreprise
française donc il faut trouver à
s'imposer à l'échelle mondiale sont
remis et notre origine est ce que ça
veut dire que votre devise va ressembler
un peu à ça 5 globaux ac locaux d'une
certaine façon même mois la devise je
les ai pas pensé comme ça j'ai pensé à
penser global agir local joliment mais
moi j'avais pensé un peu autrement ça
c'est déjà trop intelligent pour moi
mais j'ai pensé de manière très simple
la publicité c'est quoi la publicité
sont des messages qui doivent résonner
dans la tête dans le coeur des gens et
n'ont qu'à partir de là je me suis dit
ce qu'ils font c'est être proche des
gens est proche de leurs cultures et
essayer de parler dans leur culture
je vais prendre un exemple idiot mais si
on utilise une comptine française pour
parler aux philippins il ya peu de
chances qu'ils réagissent avec les mêmes
vibrations que des français qui ont été
élevés au biberon de cette comptine et
donc que je dis il faut utiliser le
langage
les cultures les et les codes de chacun
de ces pays
et c'est pour ça que j'étais parti sur
l'idée de la différence quand vous avez
cette vision là à la fin des années 80
le marché comment on vous on vous
perçoit comme quelqu un visionnaire et
qui a raison comme quelqu'un qui est
inconscient d'abord ils étaient très
prudents donc je ne me promenais pas
partout en disant on va devenir vous à
regarder nous on va devenir un géant au
mondial on va essayer de gérer des
budgets d'un certain dans le pays et on
est passé par un premier accord qui a
été une expérience extrêmement riche et
intéressante et douloureux en même temps
d un accord avec des américains et c'est
mon premier échec d'une certaine façon
avec une alliance un peu comme renault
nissan et j'ai découvert que les
alliances ne marchait pas vous voulez
vos alliés avec un américaine et s'est
très mal terminée puisque alors là si
les plus mauvais film de série b des
détectives privés me suivant aubry
communications téléphoniques étant
enregistrées les met à faire dans ma
chambre d'hôtel visiter photographie
c'est pourquoi mes papiers dans la
poubelle récupérer pourquoi mais tout
simplement parce que ils voulaient me
déstabiliser et parce que s'il pouvait
me déstabiliser dans ce pays l'avait
l'espérance de pouvoir prendre le
contrôle de publicis donc ça veut dire
que votre intuition de départ en gros
échoue dès votre première tentative de
devenir mondiale elle niche ou pas ceux
qui échouent c'est l'alliance ce qu'ils
n'échouent pas du tout c'est le concept
et c'est là où je découvre que tout les
intuitions que j'avais sur la dimension
globale tout ce que j'imaginais sur la
pénétration des marchés en et en
profondeur dans les marchés en harmonie
avec les cultures tout ceci marché
ici vous n'allez pas donc vers le marché
mondial vous pensez que publicis aurait
pu disparaître et penser qu à un moment
donné on se serait un beau gris on
aurait été une formidable agence
européenne
peut-être d'ailleurs très largement
française eco française et que notre
destin aurait pu être d'être un jour
avalée par un groupe américain
et de cela on ne voulait pas d'où la
nécessité d'aller sur le marché mondial
et 12,6 et elle est sur le marché
mondial de se développer et nous avons
fait un certain nombre d'acquisitions
avec des marques extrêmement
prestigieuse que ce sac chier ces acquis
que seul et aux grenades et avec des
positions qui font de nous un groupe
d'une très grande puissance à l'échelle
mondiale alors effectivement vous venez
de le dire vous allez faire
l'acquisition pendant 20 ans de dizaines
d'agents ce dans le monde entier pour
être présent sur les quatre continents
du globe sans augmentation de capital
sans augmentation de capital et de
l'argent à personne et vous allez
devenir numéro trois mondial et puis
arrive un mur en 2014 lorsque vous êtes
sur le point de devenir numéro un
mondial d'accord en faisant un mariage
avec le numéro un donc de la pub et de
la communication qui s'appelle omnicom
et publicis omnicom il était numéro 2
moi je dis que numéro trois et vous
devez on a souhaité faire ce qu'on
appelle une fusion entre égaux et
patatrac et sa part marcher c'est votre
rêve qui s'envole
c'est plus qu'un rêve c'est d'abord une
réflexion profonde
pourquoi faire une telle fusion c'est
parce que nous étions en train de voir
on avait la même analyse mais les les
plateformes prendre de plus en plus de
puissance de jambes et en étant google
ou facebook ou en fait les
investissements publicitaires devient le
plus important exactement et donc on
essaie de faire cette fusion 50 50
on y réussit pas mal on prévoit un
certain nombre de clauses
vous qui garantissent que les volontés
que nous avons d'être à égaliser sur un
succès et que ces clauses doivent être
mises en oeuvre avant la fusion de
manière à ce que ce soit quelque chose
de mise en place de manière indiscutable
élément qui explique l'échec un élément
je pense que à un moment donné ils se
sont dit publicis a très envie de la
fusion on va essayer de leur forcer la
main et de prendre le contrôle je pense
que ça a été le schéma qu'ils ont
d'avoir le pouvoir sur la boîte d'avoir
le pouvoir sur la boîte fusionner et de
ce lundi elisabeth badinter donc fille
de marcel bleustein blanchet et que la
gardienne des intérêts des actionnaires
ni moi qui aidais le gestionnaire
l'époque le dirigeant de la sphère n'en
avons voulu dire on n'a pas fait tout ça
on n'a pas fait tout ce parcours pour
qu'à la fin l'entreprise soit contrôlée
que ce fleuron de l'économie française
tombe entre les mains d'américains et
donc on a dit non
comment vous vivez cet échec quand même
personnellement quand quand il vivait
bon j'ai appris à connaître quelques
échecs jamais connu dans ma vie est
comme celui de ne pas pouvoir devenir
numéro 1 c'était pas des papouilles
franchement le numéro un c'était bien et
c'est sympathique c'est un badge du roi
et c'est bien c'est mieux d'être nue -
co numéro deux on m'a expliqué sa des
javelles ag six ans et comment donc vous
vivez cet effet mal
évidemment je peux pas hier que ça a été
assez douloureux
ça a été une grande réflexion avec
elizabeth bennet a d'abord avec le
conseil
ensuite et le conseil unanime a dit non
et on n'est pas là pour vendre subi si
on est là pour défendre son avenir
on avait beaucoup insisté pour soi
publicis omnicom et non pas l'inversé
et dont je vis mal et de manière un peu
amusantes
les médias américains ont été plus
gentil que les médias français pour
pour nous et les patrons américains a
acquis que j'ai informé de la décision
mondy à plus d'un que j'aurais aimé
renoncer à certaines fusions quand été
des échecs donc sagesse
vous avez raison ici ça ne correspond
plus à la réalité
vous avez raison et cela dit je suis
resté parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de
problèmes personnels je restais à ses
amis avec le patron de le patron de la
boîte et on se voit régulièrement et
tout se passe bien c'est une boîte
respectable donc il ya eu juste une
tentative
on comprend d'ailleurs dans le jeu des
affaires il y en a un qui veut imposer
son point de vue à l'autre et là on a
dit non
alors vous êtes un patron singulier
parce que vous êtes un des rares à avoir
nommé votre successeur arthur sadoun
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs vous êtes devenu
patron du conseil de surveillance et
arthur sadoun et le patron du directoire
président du directoire pourquoi est-ce
que vous continuez vous avez pas marre
je voulais partir
après la nomination d' arthur je
considérais que c'était mieux y compris
pour lui et je pensais que il fallait
que je laisse la place
il se trouve que le conseil de
surveillance et arthur lui-même ne
l'entendait pas de cette oreille
mais j'avais d'autres projets y compris
avec mes enfants
il se trouve que
non je vous aimez ça j'aime ça et puis
j'ai un devoir il faut que j'emmène le
bateau à bon port à sa teneur en fait un
boulot formidable et je suis extrêmement
fier d'avoir participé à son choix
d'allonger projet d'accompagner un
certain temps pas très longtemps jusqu'à
quand mon mandat s'arrête en 2021 et
donc en principe sauf sauf si vous
continuez en fait comme il y avait
normalement non non non et justement
demain demain votre avenir
qu'est ce que vous allez faire quand
vous serez grand alors à mon âge où mon
avenir est assez content et je veux dire
il plutôt derrière moi comme disait
pierre dac
devant moi il n'y a pas grand chose mais
ce que j'espère faire c'est d'abord bien
accompagné arthur dans sa mission
c'est d'essayer de fabriquer quelque
chose d'intéressant
et pour ça j'ai créé une affaire
familiale avec mes enfants qui s'appelle
dix corps et j'espère bien apporter une
solution aux petites entreprises c'est à
dire que j'y travaille chez un outil qui
va permettre de comics et de gérer un
certain nombre d'éléments ont souffert
bien vous arrêtez pas prendre votre
retraite
et puis vous si vous voulez je peux vous
donner un scoop je vais lancer dans pas
longtemps un incubateur qui s'adresse
aux gens qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'être accompagné qui n'ont pas les
moyens et qui n'ont pas de relations
donc en un mot les entrepreneurs qui est
des jeunes qui ont des idées et qui
n'ont pas de moyens l'isolation en le
mot si on veut résumer ce que je fais
c'est si l'ascenseur social est en panne
prenez donc l'escalator merci infiniment
tous cas merci à vous
[Musique]